but i'm gonna say something that the  maga movement might not like right now  um  this is all moral hazard  to what i was telling you earlier when  you  don't tell the truth when it's time to  tell the truth and fight and die for the  things you believe in when it's time to  that it comes back to bite you and we  talked about this 10 20 50 hypothetical  time horizon well donald trump's time  horizon on moral hazard just just  knocked on his door right now and it was  only a few years later  because what he didn't do  as america first as he was as  trade as he was as immigration as he was  as  anti-liberalism church of lgbtq drained  the swamp as he was  he didn't deconstruct the administrative  state  he didn't gut the intelligence  communities and he should have  and he had the he had the juice to at  least  lobby for